at the beginning of the show we told you
about the passing of 84 year old colin
powell the former secretary of state
whatever you thought of his role for
example in the iraq war or in the
obama campaign anyone who ever spoke to
colin powell knew conclusively he was a
legitimately impressive very smart
thoughtful patriotic person that's just
true ask someone who knew him they'll
confirm it the interesting thing as we
noted was that colin powell always said
it was probably a talking point that he
was the beneficiary of affirmative
action maybe we can't prove it but he
certainly deserved to be where he got
that's the view that's our view having
known him to be perfectly blunt about it
which is not to say affirmative action
isn't out there what else for example
but affirmative action could explain the
ascent of the former mayor of south bend
indiana
a certain sort of affirmative action
program for dwarfish frauds who once
worked for mckinsey and co
chelsea clinton may have benefited from
this as well in any case however he got
there mayor pete is somehow the
secretary of transportation at this
point and maybe it's not a coincidence
that our transportation infrastructure
has collapsed there is a supply chain
crisis and that means that shelves at
your local store of things that you
actually need to buy are empty
so mayor pete went on television the
other day finally back to work to
explain that actually the shortages the
bare shelves
they're a sign this country is thriving
retail sales are through the roof and if
you think about those images of
ships for example waiting at anchor on
the west coast you know every one of
those ships
is full of record amounts of goods that
americans are buying because demand is
up because income is up because the
president has successfully guided this
economy out of the teeth of a terrifying
recession now the issue is even though
our ports are handling more than they
ever have record amounts of goods coming
through our supply chains can't keep up
oh
so it's not it's not the
administration's fault they're doing
such a good job
that you have more money than you can
spend and because you're so rich
you want to spend it on so much stuff
that we no longer have enough stuff for
you to buy so the shortages are really
in effect your fault for being the
undeserved beneficiary of joe biden's
economic genius got that but it's
definitely not the administration's
fault that gas
and lumber
and automobiles and everything you might
actually want to buy has risen
and the things that you need to buy like
washing machines or refrigerators or
toilet paper simply aren't unavailable
and none of that is soviet no not at all
it's not the brezhnev administration no
it's utopia
be happy about it stop your complaining
says mayor pete the dwarfish fraud from
mckinsey
so that we'd bring you up to date on his
explanation for all of that and that's
what it was
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else